hola
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es alguna vez se han preguntado qué
pasaría en el planeta si se extinguiesen
los insectos
imagino que muchos sentirían alivio pero
eso solo si pensamos en aquellas
especies perjudiciales como los
mosquitos pero es importante saber que
el 99 por ciento de las especies de
insectos conocidas cumplen un rol
fundamental en los ecosistemas y sólo el
1% restante son problemáticas los
insectos son hiper abundantes e hiper
diversos más del 50% de las especies del
planeta son insectos mucho más que
vertebrados y plantas los insectos son
el corazón de las cadenas tróficas
porque otros organismos dependen de
ellos para poder vivir son los
trabajadores invisibles de los
ecosistemas porque realizan funciones
ecológicas relevantes para las personas
como por ejemplo la polinización no
tendríamos zapallos ni chocolate en
nuestra mesa ni manzanas sin el accionar
de estos pequeños organismos como las
abejas que son capaces de llevar el
polen de una flor a la otra proceso que
permite la producción de frutos
los insectos también cumplen otras
funciones como por ejemplo el ciclo de
la materia orgánica en el suelo o hay
otros que controlan naturalmente a las
plagas de nuestros cultivos a ellos los
conocemos como enemigos naturales por
ejemplo el caso de las vaquitas de san
antonio que se comen los pulgones que
atacan las plantas
en los últimos años han aparecido
estudios que demuestran que los insectos
a nivel global están en franco retroceso
por lo que si los insectos
desapareciesen se habla de un colapso
total de los ecosistemas o de un
armagedón ecológico
si bien es prematuro aseverar esto ya
que hacen falta más estudios lo cierto
es que se están perdiendo especies
drásticamente la biodiversidad a nivel
global está disminuyendo y también esto
ocurre para insectos y está demostrado
para abejas para mariposas para
escarabajos y las causas van desde el
uso desmedido de insecticidas el cambio
climático global y la pérdida de hábitat
debido a la agricultura y la
urbanización
vivimos en un mundo cada vez más
urbanizado se espera que para el año
2050 el 70% de la población viva en
ciudades
las ciudades son espacios grises
inhóspitos donde predomina el cemento y
el asfalto donde las temperaturas son
más elevadas que en la periferia donde
hay alta presencia de contaminantes y la
vegetación está reducida a parches
aislados unos de otros todas estas
condiciones generan un clima bastante
hostil para distintas especies de
animales y plantas y para nosotros
mismos también
está demostrado que un aumento en la
urbanización trae consecuencias
negativas para la biodiversidad
inclusive la de muchos grupos de
insectos
yo recuerdo cuando era chica en mi
pueblo en morteros
en las noches de verano era muy común
ver luciérnagas en el patio ya mí me
encantaba perseguir las
también me gustaban otros insectos que
como por ejemplo la mantis religiosa que
por su forma de atrapar las presas me
fascinaban pero después cuando me mudé
la gran ciudad de córdoba eso fue
cambiando ya no era tan común verlos
entonces empecé a preguntarme siendo
bióloga ya que estaba pasando con los
insectos en las ciudades
el panorama parece poco esperanzador
pero no todo está perdido
porque porque se puede revertir la
situación tratando de reverdecer las
ciudades
el verde hace bien el verde nos hace
bien está demostrado que estar
frecuentemente en contacto con espacios
verdes trae amplios beneficios para la
salud y para el bienestar humano reduce
los niveles de estrés
tiene impacto positivo en personas que
están trabajando con niños en edad
escolar y también está indicada en el
tratamiento de enfermedades mentales
cuando hablo de espacios verdes me
refiero tanto a plazas parques a
nuestros propios jardines y patios y
también a una nueva tecnología en
construcción que son los techos verdes
un techo verde implica la transformación
del techo de una vivienda o de un
edificio en una cubierta vegetal
en nuestro país es una tendencia
bastante nueva en construcción en tanto
que en países de europa hace décadas ya
que se utiliza
en el año 2016 participe hong junto a
otro grupo de colegas del primer
relevamiento de techos verdes en la
ciudad de córdoba y encontramos que
aproximadamente había 6500 metros
cuadrados de techo verde construido esa
cifra parece un montón si la vemos a sí
sola pero si la ponemos en contexto
equivale más o menos a lo que es una
cancha profesional de fútbol
y si lo comparamos con lo que pasa en
otras ciudades como por ejemplo en
santiago de chile
vemos que de santiago y chile tienen
60.000 metros cuadrados de techo verde
construido y otras ciudades como por
ejemplo en múnich en alemania tiene 3
millones de metros cuadrados de techo
verde construido ahí cambia la cosa
bueno los techos verdes tienen
beneficios varios en primer lugar para
la vivienda en términos energéticos
porque en verano por ejemplo no es
necesario encender el aire acondicionado
ya que esa cubierta vegetal funciona
como un aislante térmico y cuando en una
ciudad hay una red interconectada de
techos verdes eso tiene beneficios
ambientales para la ciudad porque porque
disminuye la temperatura de la ciudad
ayuda en la retención del agua de lluvia
evitando las inundaciones y también
mejora la calidad del aire y por
supuesto brinda hábitat a distintas
especies de animales y plantas incluidos
los insectos este aspecto es el que
menos se había estudiado y menos aún
para países de latinoamérica por eso
hace un par de años junto a mi equipo de
investigación realizamos un estudio en
la provincia de córdoba donde estudiamos
30 techos verdes y efectivamente
comprobamos que los insectos hacían uso
de estos nuevos ambientes encontramos
aproximadamente 500
y diferentes de insectos con 13.000
individuos a lo largo de los 30 techos
verdes
encontramos desde mariposas pequeñas
polillas chicharritas abejas abejorros
una variedad de insectos que pudimos
comprobar que estaban cumpliendo
funciones ecológicas diferentes en esos
pequeños ecosistemas en ese mismo
estudio también al comparar la riqueza
de especies de insectos en los techos
verdes versus hábitat a nivel de suelo
encontramos que los techos verdes
tuvieron un 50% menos de especies que
los hábitat en el suelo
esto sugiere que si bien los techos
verdes son beneficiosos para los
insectos porque ellos hacen uso de estos
nuevos ambientes
no reemplazan a hábitat a nivel de suelo
que se pierden
en ese mismo estudio también pudimos ver
que muchos de los dueños originalmente
habían colocado césped en los techos y
como esto requiere mucho mantenimiento
después habían decidido dejar de
cuidarlo y esos techos habían sido
colonizados espontáneamente por
distintas plantas del lugar y lo que
vimos fue súper interesante porque
aquellos techos que tuvieron una mayor
diversidad de especies de plantas
tuvieron una mayor diversidad de
especies de insectos benéficos
particularmente los enemigos naturales
que les contaba anteriormente
todos estos resultados nos dieron
piernas a que nos hiciéramos nuevas
preguntas y actualmente estamos llevando
a cabo un experimento en la ciudad de
córdoba donde gracias al apoyo de
national geographic instalamos 30 techos
experimentales en distintas viviendas de
la ciudad y estamos comparando el efecto
de plantas nativas que son las
originarias de una región como por
ejemplo de nuestras sierras de córdoba
ver sus plantas exóticas que son las que
comúnmente se utilizan ya que justamente
como les decía antes los techos verdes
son una tecnología importada entonces la
vegetación que generalmente se usa es de
otro lado y queremos ver cuál es el
efecto de esto sobre la diversidad y
abundancia de insectos como resultado
preliminar les puedo contar que
encontramos una mayor abundancia de
insectos en las plantas nativas tal como
esperamos
ustedes se preguntarán para qué sirven
todos estos resultados bueno son la
línea de base es fundamental para poder
hacer un llamado a la sociedad toda de
que empecemos a tomar conciencia de
estos temas de la importancia de los
insectos y del rol que tienen los
espacios verdes en las ciudades
es importante que todos con pequeñas
acciones podamos contribuir a la
conservación de insectos desde no matar
a todo que anda por ahí porque si
si un mosquito capas que hay si le damos
hasta otras acciones como por ejemplo
decidir instalar un techo verde en
nuestra casa o bien si tenemos que
plantar un árbol elegir una especie
nativa frente a una exótica
también otra cosa que puede sumar es que
si aparecen plantas de crecimiento
espontáneo en nuestro jardín o en
nuestro patio no las cortamos porque si
las dejemos porque especies como por
ejemplo el diente de león sus flores
ofrecen recursos alimenticios a las
abejas u otras como por ejemplo la
margarita punzo atrae mariposas
y otros profesionales vinculados a la
temática como arquitectos paisajistas e
ingenieros también pueden contribuir a
la problemática porque creo que es
posible conciliar lo que es estética y
diseño con ecología
sin embargo nada de esto alcanza si no
hay políticas de planificación urbana
que acompañen
en muchas ciudades del mundo existen
leyes que fomentan o que obligan la
instalación de techos verdes aquí en
córdoba en el año 2016 en la ciudad se
salió una ordenanza que obliga a la
instalación de techos verdes en zonas
céntricas de la ciudad esto es súper
valioso porque por que korda es una de
las pocas ciudades de latinoamérica que
tiene una ley en este sentido sin
embargo aún falta mucho por recorrer
porque la ordenanza aún no ha sido
reglamentada imagínense como nos
podríamos posicionar en la región de
continuar este camino
sólo así podremos cambiar la realidad de
las ciudades en que vivimos
contribuyendo a evitar el tan temido
armageddon ecológico
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]